well this is great but it before but as
mellon was saying i last two talks that
i gave were doing the life of IFI this
talk will be about everything that I
learned in the last 11 plus years of
studying I fight so quick favor if you
guys were okay with it
please don't tweet and don't do social
media because we had the exit less than
a year ago so there are some rules
around talking about exits by the SEC
and all this stuff so just keep
everything you know among us and ask me
questions I it's being videotaped so
that's okay just don't tweet in
real-time
that'd be awesome thank you so how we
start this is a photo of about ten years
ago I was as tall but I was probably
little thinner
those are my three other co-founders
that was our first meeting at Sand Hill
Road
so were four friends and you've I was
one of my first friends is actually in
the US since I was 13 years old I met
Barron in any regime through Val about
twenty years ago I've been in the u.s.
says 85 I'm Israeli mega var would we
were in eighth grade in the East Coast
and we started I wanted to make cameras
more fun to use and easier to share
photos this is before you know the
iPhone so remember around 2006 digital
imaging was going at a massive rate up
cameras became digital it was totally
awesome
but getting images under the camera was
a massive pain you took it the card out
of the camera to put in put an 80
computer upload download sort it took
energy not rocket science you guys are
all technical so it's easy for you to do
but for the mom and the dad that have
kids that are busy it takes energy to
actually stop you know what you're doing
and do it sure doing dishes is it sure
getting stuff
a lot of a camera is also a chore so
well we came up with actually during
that meeting was the time to actually
switched around our idea we actually
came up with a USB stick a USB stick was
going to suck out the images out of the
camera and we want to model the photo
industry so you go to a Costco Walgreens
CVS it used to be that you dump your
film in the canister in the you know big
film dump and then you get photos after
half an hour and that's how you used to
be so actually it was very simple just
took pictures you went to CVS or
Walgreens
the little clerk would puff some air
into the camera give you a new roll film
and I was an entire market and in fact
flip had you know a camera that was
called a flip cam before they actually
had the Flip camcorder there was around
going into CVS getting the digital
camera you know replaced with new flash
and you got photos out of it but cameras
became really cool and they became
really really easy to use but the part
that happened after the click see the
click is very easy the part that happens
after the click is very hard so we came
up with a USB stick but the VCS and Sand
Hill Road said hey you guys are for
geeks you are clueless about retail you
have no idea how to do how to approach
Best Buy Walmart Target and you're
basing your entire future on this memory
stick that would be dumped into the film
canister they would give the customers
photos are out of the camera
we had IP around having that USB stick
protected you would stick to the camera
it would only accept the cameras images
and videos out you couldn't actually see
in anything in it same way as film was
and when you put the stake back into the
retailer's bin they will give you photos
back and they would re unlock the stick
so you have patents on this but the VCS
said you guys are smoking crack nobody
would actually do this because there's
no reason to actually
believe that you four could do this so
idea number two was a memory card the
memory card was gonna basically be a
smart memory card so instead of taking
photos and having them stored on a
memory card that goes into your shoe box
as a roach motel the card would do
everything for you in the background so
you focus on taking pictures have fun do
other magic with the camera and the
eye-fi card does everything for you so
that's what that's what we came up with
that drawing the you see on the left is
the first schematic drawing that my
co-founder did overnight my co-founders
are such amazing rockstars of
Engineering they're the reason that I
left engineering and became a business
development guy in marketing and sales
because they're just so good at no
reason for me through you know you know
I'm even attempt so the the schematic
was the first thing that we did to prove
we country cram a radio a transceiver
flash a CPU a crystal all onto the card
so we did that overnight the middle card
do you see is the world's most expensive
memory card that was about four grand to
make because the mold for the plastic
was about four grand but that's that
happened after three months we built out
the card we proved that we weren't
smoking crack we could do everything on
our own Behrend wrote firmware for his
own chip which he designed for atheros
if there was is now on buy buy buy leave
quo tomorrow Broadcom but there were
radios back then by Broadcom Marvel and
atheros which was atheros the big chip
that you see is the flash the middle
chip above that is the controller
because the reason the rights between
the camera and and and the shape and the
the load chip on the top right corner is
the crystal that does the radio
frequency so 2.4 gigahertz 5.8 4 n G
so that was the card that we made after
a few months all the way fast-forward to
our newest card which we made before we
got acquired about six months ago that
card had half a gig a net today's cards
had three two gigs of course it can do
64 128 you know it actually even a
terabyte but that card is what we had
the very last card that we had before we
actually sold the company so that's the
history between that I'll talk about a
little bit of what we did it's hard to
see we raised about 50 million dollars
during this the last Bend of the company
so by all measures were firing on all
cylinders we raised in a after we had
revenue from beta we had beta that
basically we presold 10,000 cards and
hundred bucks each
we couldn't even afford to make them but
we actually sold beer cards this is
before Kickstarter before IndieGoGo so
we in a way crowd funded our company
because we then raised the money yet
from the VCS
but we raised from angel so I actually
raised a million dollars for us with my
co-founder the first year so we raised a
million from angels then we had beta
then we had revenue we're revenue so
then we raised the a five and a half
million on the a paired with 1 million
from the seed uncomfortable note same
rules us today main differences we had
no caps back then today you actually
have a cap on convertible note launched
the company actually pre launched it by
mistake lessons learned never pre-launch
until you actually ready so 2006 q3 we
actually launched in retail we were
finally ready we raised our money we
hired a new CEO to help us with a retail
launch and we launched at Amazon and
bestbuy.com Cosmo comm all of their
online retailers but not bigger motor so
just online it was easier for us to
maintain our inventory
as a small company and now go into mass
retail learn from our mistakes do it
only online and then after you after you
know we learn from our mistakes we then
went into mass retail we raised a B and
a C every year and a half
typically you raise venture so every day
every time the arrays you raise
hopefully on an up round otherwise he
doing it down round it means you
actually have more dilution and it's
horrible each one of our raises was
always an up round so six and a half
twelve eighteen and twenty a last round
was from DoCoMo DoCoMo gave us twenty
million dollars to build their cloud and
that was on a valuation of about 120
million post so grew the company had
sales in every major retailer in every
major country 48 countries sold millions
of cards online brick-and-mortar
globally so pretty much you can see
every major retailer from every country
in every region we've covered it was
totally awesome we also did something
really really major these memory cards
were being seen by the camera as a
memory card only but the card had to up
had to upload the photos Twitter your
phone this is fast-forwarding now now
the cards are going to your phone or
your iPad or your Android or your
computer at home or the cloud anywhere
they're going everywhere so the court
has to upload and it needs power if he
doesn't have power it can't upload the
power is being given to it by the camera
so the card slot is powering it if the
camera is being turned off there's no
power we can't upload so we had deals
with every major camera company in Japan
actually also Korea and Germany but most
of the companies are in Japan so a top
12 OEMs put firmware in the camera for
us that we
basically mean that if the kind sorry if
they swing my my cough drop if the
camera so the card is still uploading it
would still keep power to the card slot
when the card was done uploading it
would tell the camera turn off and the
camera turned off this is pretty
monumental for small company in the Bay
Area to have the inroads with twelve of
the biggest camera companies in the
world go into tens of millions of units
shipped so first it was Nikon we didn't
believe that they actually when they
came to us well she didn't believe they
would not screw us but we were told that
if somebody from from Japan comes to you
and they and they promise you that
actually you will work with you you
should trust them
best thing we've done because Nikon
supported us in the camera and when
Nikon did everybody else followed suit
so I caught stacking
don't go after after your tier 1 o a.m.
or you know dream come true company at
first go after tier 2 or tier 3 in our
case mekin actually is when the top we
come companies but once they believe in
us and once they put us into their
firmware of other cameras everybody else
followed suit and like literally there's
no company today that makes cameras that
doesn't have Wi-Fi support in the camera
even though they even if they have Wi-Fi
built in today they have I Phi because I
figure actually does the Wi-Fi better so
by every measure we're doing everything
right
we hired awesome CEOs we kept growing we
up we opened offices all over so we had
enough us in Europe and F was in Asia
and office here in LA totally awesome
had major deals with every major camera
guy and major deals with every major
retailer so we're firing and also unders
so what we should have done is exit then
and we had chances to and
we had the most amazing fun I mean we're
seeing success we're seeing sales keep
growing the camera the camera industry
even though it's trying to flatten out
because of smartphones as a camera as
cameras became flat and flat means
instead of selling 80 million you know a
year units they sold 70 million units
here still a big market we added more
countries in more areas and more
continents and more distribution so as
the camera industry's tried to flat and
go down we still grew and year-over-year
we still did the right thing we still
grew the business we still became more
and more profitable it was just totally
amazing to see the company grow but we
didn't exit so it's actually the last
thing you want to do when you're having
fun
literally when you're having fun you
don't want to stop and that's the
biggest lesson that if you guys take
home from today when you're having the
most fun you're gonna have chances to
exit and people will come to you and
offer you maybe meaningful offers maybe
you know maybe not but you will not be
thinking about it all you're thinking
about growing the business hiring doing
the best thing for the business and for
your investors which usually doesn't
mean stopping soon it means keep keep
the business going and growing it but we
should be doing is when you have the
most fun that's when you exit so you
really this is a major major lesson and
I think the companies like YouTube
they're it right companies like
histogram that are right there are many
companies that thought that they would
not catch it right and didn't want it
because they thought that if the exit
they would lose their culture or lose
their team lose their products maybe but
usually what happens is when you get
acquired or when you exit you actually
have more funding to do yours
and you have more revenue and more
resources to actually work on your baby
so putting it into into you know actual
graph because you guys are all engineers
so you geeky so I get it so your life or
the company will be a massive chaos
you'll have ups and downs it's gonna be
insane
overall though you should see the trend
going up and you'll feel it employees
feel it you as a co-founder feel will
feel it your VCS will feel it if you
don't go up overall even though you'll
have tons of bumps in the road you'll
know your place will know they will
leave you excusable know they'll put
pressure on you to put in a new CEO or
hire a new VP of Marketing we've gotten
through all that stuff but overall we
had a massive beautiful you know yeah
graph up so you'll feel it and as you
feel it you really should be thinking
when do you actually exit so here is
putting everything into a picture that's
the optimal exit is when you're having
the most fun and that's what what I will
keep claiming and that's what people
will argue that you should keep having
fun and and keep you know building the
business but actually if you time it
right the optimal way to make the most
for your investors for your employees
for yourself is when you having the most
fun most companies missed that point if
I did they some companies some some
entrepreneurs catch it right on top and
mind-blowing I mean for example the
founder of flip salt flat to Cisco
cut it right on top he's brilliant in
raising money he's brilliant in exiting
Cisco a year and half later killed flip
because they knew that the smartphone is
gonna kill the camcorder industry but
flip they're an amazing job they were
into retail they had the best camera out
there with a single red button it was
amazing
they hurt the entire camcorder industry
and they had the best product and they
had the best time to exit so they
literally call it were on top because
they were about to crest and Jonathan
Kaplan had off to him did an amazing job
and there are a few other cases but not
many
most companies either go down most go
down and they had a curve but they
didn't even realize they actually had a
curve there so that they fume out the
amount of money whatever but you know
most companies go down some of them had
the chance but didn't and some do exit
and that's where I fight was they exit
but there's a too late so by the time
that you exit your market is trying to
shrink everyone knows it so your offers
gonna come in at a lower price so I Phi
Han exit made some money could have made
way more money if we did earlier so
that's the big lesson learned that only
a very very very small portion of
companies do time it right most never
time it and some will time it but they
will time it incorrectly so you're
asking you know if you're having fine
why actually stop and if you're having
fun and you're stopping because you've
exited will you literally stop having
fun and the answer is no you will not
you will keep having fun because you'll
have more of these resources so for
example take let's take an Instagram for
example they were big but they became
way bigger as part of Facebook because
they hired the resources YouTube was big
they became infinitely bigger heard of
Google they didn't lose the culture they
lose the core they didn't lose any other
parks did they became massive because of
Google's funding so the founders made
money and they kept growing it so it's
not the case that if you actually exit
you will lose out in many cases you will
not and this is
really the biggest lesson that that we
learned had I had this insight five
years ago when we raised our twenty
million on 120 I would have exited then
we had we had offers throughout the the
company's history and we always wanted
to just keep building the business and
keep doing what we're doing and that was
a mistake
will they company that choirs you kill
your culture sometimes but those those
things are all negotiable so let's say
they're you're getting an offer to be
acquired and right now by the way I'm in
the middle of doing it again but this
time I'm that time it actually right so
my current company were in the middle of
an M&A process and that's why I'm saying
don't tweet and we're actually gonna
time it right we realized there was a
window we're doing it right but this
time the management team is much much
more senior than what we were when we
were doing it and that's really why I
joined them and so it's possible that
your culture will be changed but all
those things could be negotiated if you
get acquired you can say keep my company
here keep my my building here keep my
core engineers here or you can say okay
I'm okay
moving over to you guys but all those
things are negotiable and the most
seniority that you have in doing this
they the more likely you were to
actually have an outcome that is good
for you guys the founders and for the
and the employees and the VCS that's it
short sweet let's have questions thank
you
[Applause]
yeah so the question was how do I think
of Facebook that had a chance to exit
didn't and of course they they were
right by not exiting absolutely with
with a business like everything in life
there's tons of luck that plays into
this so certain dippity something that
usually you know you actually talk about
in MBA school engineering school you
talk about building bits and bytes and
that if you do the right thing you'll
grow the business luck is a massive
force in business luck sir and dippity
completely massive massive forces who
knows what would have happened Facebook
of course is amazing today but there are
only a few Facebook's if your instagrams
few YouTube's I'm sure to tell you guys
how to do it when you not that size and
don't hope for a Facebook you know
everyone hopes for a Facebook and
Instagram in YouTube
great but I'm being pragmatic here I'm
saying you probably will not be a
Facebook or snapchat also snapshots they
had offers to get quite for 1 billion
two billion five billion than 10 billion
they now just raised four billion
they're gonna IPO so they held out
awesome I hope that they succeed you
never know but because they demi IPO and
who knows what'll happen after after
that I'd IPO but they held out they are
doing the right thing
probably for them and they held out but
had they exited at 1 billion two or
three when they were offered to be
acquired by Facebook for example who
knows if they would have changed their
path or not you just you just don't know
but there is a saying you know a bird in
the hand you know is better than nothing
right
so the Bay Area tries to tell you to go
for these massive billion-dollar exits
and hold out for the massive exit and
until you hold out for that you're not
gonna be good when I'm saying it's
better to have a few small exits keep
doing that and keep having the exits and
keep building value for your
shareholders and for yourself versus
hold out for 10 years and then maybe or
maybe not exit any more questions yeah
so question was sorry non-coffee
question was my dad washed out or do I
have plans to have more fun no no we're
gonna keep having fun and I'm 44 I have
at least 20 years of work and even if I
could if tomorrow I retired I would
probably still keep working so I want to
keep doing this because because being
entrepreneur is really a disease because
you keep doing it even though it's the
worst thing ever
you get crap from every angle and it's
the hardest thing that you'll ever do
and you're gonna keep doing it so I'm
gonna keep doing it and but while I'm
doing it I'm gonna try to actually exit
and make money out of it while having
fun but it really is a disease because
you get punished and you keep doing it
so right now I'm at a company that was
started by one of my IFI co-founders and
we started to actually build out a smart
camera so we're building a smart camera
and we have an amazing company in Japan
that's sponsoring us to build a smart
camera
and at the same time we actually
realized that while building this smart
camera everything that we built for this
technology in terms of Android and Linux
being real time and hard wheel time and
vision can be applied to many things
like robotics like cars like cameras
anything that needs real hard time Linux
and Android so we're selling we finished
the project for this company in Japan
and I'm on the road selling having
having a blast and this time we had time
and right and then after this I'll
hopefully make tons of money keep doing
it
it's just can't can't can't stop so the
question was while we were building it
how did we protect ourselves from
companies stealing it execution so we
have patents we have many patents filed
and for seven years we had no
competitors because what we do actually
is really hard to do in terms of I mean
we really built the world's most
computer it's a real it's a real
computer with the tcp/ip stack it's
doing a lot of things that your DOMA
computer does but it's inside a memory
card but doing that well is really
really hard so eventually seven years
later a company in China started to copy
us but it did a horrible job
horrible horrible job sorry that went
nowhere because it really is hard to
make to talk to actually do right and
even if you did do it right they didn't
have all of our deals with the camera
guys so even if the card came in they
couldn't emulate our IFI card because we
had IP there was with the camera guys so
it's not patents patents will never
protect you because big companies will
come in and hurt you and you can't
afford to actually sue them because
they're just massive and you small so it
really is execution we kept hammering it
and we kept doing amazing things and we
kept growing eventually we had
- Sheba in Japan do an okay job what we
didn't do right is we file their patents
in the US and in Europe and now in Japan
of course we didn't do China because
China there's no reason to file anything
there because this is pointless
but Japan we should have filed we didn't
Toshiba went after us even though their
card was inferior to ours they actually
went after us in Japan and Japan was our
home turf because we did all these
camera deals so that did start to hurt
today if you go to our fights website
and you see click and they were debye it
points you to toshiba's amazon card so
he actually did as we exit cell portion
of us of our IP to Toshiba and the
company is not part of reco Pentax so
our exit was selling the cloud part the
cloud they for structure the entire app
layer to reco Pentax and the card
business to Toshiba so they wanted to
actually have our IP in the cameras and
they couldn't so they bought a part but
for the most part you can't have any any
protection it's just your execution ok
so the question is how's the landscape
changing for venture capital this year
will be a good year because they were
really worried for a while so they
actually sat on their funds so they were
sitting under funds for a long time for
about two years because of worried you
know what'll happen so this year will be
a year so they have these massive funds
they're sitting on so they're actually
have to actually start to spend it so
you see a good year for venture capital
but it's gonna be the same thing these
will always invest when there's
commotion on the street so if you go
Sand Hill Road and if you have one VC
that's interested they all go to you
know the Madera restaurant ascending
Road right does that hotel and the
restaurant always hang out
what's this commotion in the streets
you'll get calls from other VCS as well
so what will happen is you have to
create commotion and that'll always be
the case you you know they will go for
ideas that they believe are only good if
they've been funded by angels well you
should have probably asked this how's
the angel market to change you because
the VCS market hasn't has really changed
that much their bankers they have LPS
LPS or colleges usually they invest in
the fund so the VC market hasn't really
changed the model the Angels have
changed because the angels are the ones
who actually got screwed by the VCS so
used to be that there was no cap on the
convertible note term sheets now there
are caps but still happens as angels get
washed out by the VCS
so they realize they get washed out
AngelList try becoming big but finding
an angel an angel list is tough because
the only gov companies devotee had
funding before so it's sort of like you
know a particular neg so if you have
some funding for as a family you can go
to angel list and you can get some
funding from some angels but the way
that has changed is now they have these
syndicates and the syndicates work like
VC funds but the not a VC found they're
actually a collection of small angels
they go in together so your parents your
parents your sister different family can
be a syndicate and you wouldn't take
their money because they were your
parents or your family and you shouldn't
take their money because the body is not
very green and if you want our mission
what I mean by that but a syndicate is a
basket of other angels that are taking
the risk together because there's one
guy who's controlling their syndicate
who's who who gets a caring same way as
we cease do so the VC is gonna carry by
managing the company and so they're
controlling manager or the syndicate on
AngelList
has a carry so when any company is in
the basket of the company's exit they
get more from their fund so Angelus
really changed it and syndicates really
changed the angel platform so that way
the Angels get screwed less
any more questions yep
how did you meet with your co-founders
and determine but this is a very
personal drug to calculate okay so a
question was how do we meet as
co-founders and how do we decide this is
the right thing to do so I so oh that's
right in two ways
start a company with people that you
love and people that you're friends with
because you're gonna see them way more
than gonna be seeing your spouse or your
partner so we're friends and we started
it with a belief that we can change the
camera industry we had an idea we had
two different ideas that kind of morphed
into one idea but we had we saw this
need and he wanted to solve it and we
saw that nobody else is offing it so we
started having you know meetups we still
had our day jobs and we still got a
salary I'm a huge fan of not stopping
cold turkey and not stopping the money
flowing in because if it does then
you'll be really really hard-pressed to
sometimes make the wrong decisions if
you actually have some income flowing in
the beginning you can save that when
you're young that's awesome you can save
up and if you're still single you don't
have the mortgage and the kids I I
already had the mortgage and the kids so
and it was still painful we had hot dogs
for a year but we went full-time when we
raised our first angel because then we
knew okay we have something here it was
easy to raise for the first angel and
after having him we had the next 11 also
fairly easily so I'm a fan of
bootstrapping it's for as long as you
can keep your day job when you have a
team around you that believes in you and
your co-founders believe in you and you
believe in them then you can go
full-time in terms of finding
co-founders meetups if you don't have a
networking so hire network I've been
here for since 80 since 92
after nine but 92 was my first full-time
here
so I've been here for by then about 10
years 15 years so I didn't network if
you have no network meetups
there's tons of meetups ok so question
was if you compare Angels to VCS which
ones are the easiest to get funds from
angels will be the ones who believe in
your dream and they'll give you 50 K
hierarchy and then there's the super
angels that give you millions but if you
go for friends and family I would say
only go for friends and family that have
at least a net worth of a million
dollars so if they give you 50 K they
won't come after you if you actually
lost at the 50k because the odds are you
will you will lose their money much more
than you actually make the money so
their money is not as green as a VC they
can actually give you introductions for
example so what happens is when you go
to angels you should go for angels that
for them 50k is for the normal person
look like 5 bucks 10 bucks it means
nothing to them so if they can spend on
you 50k it doesn't come off the bottom
line is easy for them to actually accept
so angels are way easier because there
are many more of them most of the Apple
Facebook Google employees are angels you
know anyone with at least 1 million
dollar of net worth can be an accredited
investor an investor can invest 50k and
above and I wouldn't take money for less
than 50k because if you take money from
25k or 10k for example it costs my to
take money so if you inve you take money
from an angel and their a friend of
yours but the only wire to give you 25 K
that's dangerous because they couldn't
feel comfortable with 50k or hurric a
25k is not a lot and it means that they
had enough pain to give you 50
and it means that if you actually do
lose the money 25 to them will be a lot
more meaningful than a million or ten
million to a VC so their money is less
green than the VC is money but they're
easy to get my friend so other any
positions aren't the number of investors
no so if the more you raise the more you
dilute so the way that it works is you
have a cap table and the cap table can
keep growing and the Millennials that
you take money from the more pieces of
company you gave up so your evaluation
and evaluation there are three buckets
typically in the Bay Area and there's
West Coast Rosen as east coast rules the
West Coast rules have West Coast term
sheets which means that you're gonna
store the company and you incorporate
and you create 10 million shares and if
you're a one founder you have 10 million
shares to yourself and that's every
country the incorporates has 10 million
shares if you two co-founders and you
equally split family in each accept that
you build you say have 4 million each
and you and you and you leave 2 million
for the employee pool now that 2 million
is then gonna be shared among their
other investors because you have come
and shares and yet preferred shares so
you make shares so every time you
actually give money away so whenever you
actually take money in from from
investors you give stock away and that
stock dilutes you and your co-founders
and your employees so let's say that
you're in the bucket of 0 6 million then
there's 6 to 8 and then there's 8 to 12
if you're in is your to 6 million bucket
which means you have no traction and no
revenue nothing your baby and you take
him let's say six are ok you've now
given away 10% of the company so fine
but that's her ok was important to you
so for you 10%
it's meaningful if you took in a million
dollars you give away a lot more than
10% because you've capped with six
million if we cap was ten million or 20
million you'll give away less but the
problem with being over capitalized
which means you have a huge huge
valuation which means that you think oh
I'm cool I'm amazing I'm gonna have this
massive relation because I want to have
myself and my my employees dilute this
problem is if you dilute less and if you
have a massive valuation and say 20
million or 30 million and then you want
to go and raise a your a has to now be
50 million or 80 million your your H
phone has to be higher than the previous
one otherwise it's a down round so if
you go for way too high on the seed or
on the a you screw yourself over and you
becoming over capitalized
my name is the many founders and make
that mistake we didn't but many founders
do so we were a very conservative our
six and a half million was a Novation of
12 pre 18 Post right so that the 12 plus
the 6 is 18 our B was on inflation of 25
our C was inflation of 40 and our D was
an aviation of 120 sold each each round
we grew the valuation that that's how
you do it if you don't do that and
you're not conservative at the beginning
what happens is you will show yourself
in the foot later on and he will hurt
and you'll lose employees it happens to
many companies
more questions
and funding or anything you want as you
can see I'm pretty much open book thank
you guys
[Applause]
you